الى حد ما تتشابه ملامحهما مع فارق في
الطول حتى ملابسهما قد تتطابق احيانا
وكلاهما ترعرع في مدينه كريفيريه وفي
اربعينيه العمر تخاله صارما متجهما
فتقطيبه حاجبيه قد لا تنفك ابدا
اما عيناه فلا تفارقان
فهو ظله المخلص الذي لا يغيب لا في
الميدان ولا في المحافل الرسميه قيل عنه
زيلينسكي الاخر انه مكسيم دونيتس
الحارس الشخصي للرئيس الاوكراني منذ بدايه
حياته السياسيه في 2019
وقبلها كان يلازم الملياردير الاوليجار شي
ايجار كولوميسكي لكنه وبعد ازمه اوكرانيا
حظي بشعبيه مليونيه على تيك توك وبدا
المستخدمون يبحثون عن تفاصيل حياته
ليجدوا ان الرجل الذي درس الاقتصاد في
جامعه فاديم هيتمان لا يمتلك منزلا ويقطن
في وحده عسكريه
ومدخراته لا تتجاوز العشره الاف دولار